well we begin with breaking news now out
of the U.S where Democrats will hang on
to control of the Senate after a midterm
election victory in Nevada Catherine
Cortes masto has defeated her Republican
opponent Adam laxalt who was endorsed by
Donald Trump it means the Democrats will
continue to hold a majority in the
senate for the remainder of President
Biden's term in office Cortez masto's
Victory is a huge win for Democrats and
a blow to Republicans who had hope for a
red wave to give them the balance of
power in both the Senate and the House
of Representatives let's bring in Mike
Hannah he joins us live from Washington
D.C for more mics the Democrats must be
breathing a huge sigh of release talk us
through the Nevada result on what it
means
well it's very significant indeed it
does give the Democrats control of the
Senate it gives them 50 seats to date
which with the controlling vote of the
vice president means that they will
control the senate for yet another term
now the Senate leader Chuck Schumer has
just announced that this is a
Vindication for all Americans saying
that he will again be the leader of the
Senate the majority leader in the Senate
and he said as well that this makes
clear that the American people reject
the mega brand of republicanism now what
is significant in these last three
Senate results we've seen Pennsylvania
Arizona and now in Nevada each of these
candidates was heartily endorsed by
former president Donald Trump now this
is going to impact very greatly his
standing and outsize influence within
the Republican Party given his record in
terms of backing candidates who have
lost in states that the Republicans were
confident they could take back from the
Democrats so a very very significant
Democratic party Victory control of the
Senate there is still going to be a
runoff election in Georgia but that in a
way is immaterial given that the
Democrats have already seized control of
the Senate as to the house elections
well the counting is continuing there
the Republicans appear to still be
having a slight lead however there's
been a narrowing in that lead over the
past 24 hours with some surprising
results coming out particularly in
California so the race for the house as
well does not yet appear to be over if
the Republicans do win control there
it's going to be by the slimmest of
margins which will heavily impact on
their ability to push through whatever
agenda they want to in the house all
right my kind of life was there in
Washington D.C Mike thank you all right
let's bring in John Nichols he's a
political writer at the nation he joins
us live from Madison in Wisconsin John
good to have you back with us so Nevada
is a race as Mike was saying there that
went right down to the wire President
Biden and the Democrats will be
extremely happy with this result
absolutely this is incredibly good news
for President Biden what it means is
that on a number of levels he will now
have the power to continue to govern
something that he would have lost in
many senses if the Republicans had taken
the senate for instance with Democratic
control of the U.S Senate President
Biden's appointments to the high court
are our Supreme Court as well as to the
federal courts and to Cabinet positions
ambassadorships other jobs can now be
approved in a way that they might not
have been approved by a Republican
Senate so right off the bat that is a
big deal also whether the Republicans
take the House of Representatives or not
because the Democrats have controlled
the Senate they will be in a negotiating
position where they'll be able to
advance much of the president's agenda
so this is a huge victory for President
Biden and for the Democrats and and John
with the Democrats take taking the
Senate this is a huge blow for
Republicans who were hoping of course
for this red wave of votes to Route the
Democrats it never happened though so do
you think voters punished Republicans
for their policies on big issues like
inflation and abortion and so on
I think it was a complicated election I
think that voters were ill at ease as
regards inflation they're concerned
about rise in prices and if that was the
only issue the Republicans might have
done rather well but on the issue of
abortion overwhelmingly the polls showed
that the voters sided with the Democrats
on the issue of protecting American
democracy making sure that we have free
and fair elections the polls showed that
the people sided with the Democrats and
on the issue of maintaining our social
safety net particularly our social
security program the polls showed that
the people sided with the Democrats so
even though inflation was a big issue
and a challenging issue for the
Democrats on a host of other issues
people were with them and I think this
is also somewhat of a referendum on
Donald Trump and there's a very powerful
signal that a lot of Voters even in
republican-leading states are ill at
ease with Donald Trump and his endorsed
candidates yeah and meanwhile the
Republicans appear to be inching closer
to majority in the house what does this
mean then for the last two years of
President Biden's presidency
well it's certainly a problem for
President Biden if Republicans control
the House of Representatives President
Biden will have to negotiate with the
Republicans in his first two years he
had a democratic house and a Democratic
Senate his main job was just to get the
Democrats together that wasn't always
easy but that was all he had to do now
he will have to reach across the aisle
and look for compromises with the
Republicans to get action in the house
that will be much harder it's certainly
going to be a challenge but if it's a
narrow Republican majority then that's
going to be easier than if it's a big
Republican majority and it certainly
looks at this point like it'll be quite
narrow John just just a final thought to
you I mean this string of wins for the
Democrats has seen a stunning reversal
of Fortune for the party that appeared
to be in serious trouble heading into
the midterms but can the Democrats do
you think maintain this momentum going
forward into 2024.
uh it it is certainly possible it
depends in many ways on what the
Republican Party does if the Republican
Party remains closely aligned with
Donald Trump that gives the Democrats
some space to work in but ultimately
presidents and parties are measured by
what they accomplish and so the next two
years will be challenging for the
Democrats but the fact that they made it
through this midterm with frankly a lot
of Victories uh suggests that they have
some ability to succeed politically
where people didn't think it was
possible so the Democrats are feeling
very good tonight Joe Nichols always
good to get your thoughts and your
Insight thank you very much indeed for
talking to us John thank you